In this segment we will go
very fast through a few
definitions and facts
that remain true in
the continuous case.
Everything is completely
analogous to
the discrete case.
And there are absolutely
no surprises here.
So, for example, we have defined
joint PMFs for the
case of more than two discrete
random variables.
And we have a bunch of
facts about them.
In a similar manor, we can
define joint PDFs for more
than two random variables.
And if you have understood the
material so far, you can guess
how such a joint PDF
will be used.
For example, you can calculate
the probability of a three
dimensional set by integrating
the joint PDF over that three
dimensional set.
And there are analogs off all of
the other formulas that we
have here where we follow
the usual recipe.
Sums become integrals, and PMFs
are replaced by PDFs.
Finally, when you deal with a
random variable, which is
defined as a function of jointly
continuous random
variables, we can use an
expected value rule that takes
the same form as in
the discrete case.
And using the expected value
rule, we can establish, once
more, the usual linearity
properties of expectations.
So absolutely no
surprises here.
The derivations are either
completely straightforward.
Or they follow exactly the same
line of argument as in
the discrete case, with just
minor changes in notation.